MAX SALTONSTALL: Hey, Sara,
if I know some people who
want to build a machine-learning
pipeline end-to-end on GCP,
could you help?
SARA ROBINSON: Absolutely.
It's an area I know pretty well.
How can I help?
MAX SALTONSTALL:
Could you walk me
through a real-world example?
SARA ROBINSON: No problem.
We've got a demo
that shows you how
to predict the price
of a bottle of wine
with nothing more than its
description and variety.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Really?
You don't even need to know the
name or the year of the wine?
SARA ROBINSON: Nope, we can
get everything we need just
from those two things.
Give me five minutes, and I'll
show you a wine prediction
model.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, let me explain
how our model works.
The trick to predicting the
price of a bottle of wine
without needing to
know the name or year
is to use a model that allows
us to extract more meaning
from the wine's description.
We can't feed the raw text
of our wine descriptions
directly to the
model, so we'll first
need to encode it in
a numerical format
that our model can understand.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So we turn the
words into arrays of numbers,
so our description
is in a format
that the ML algorithms
can more easily use?
SARA ROBINSON: Yes.
And there are many
ways to transform text.
If we use multiple types
of transformations at once,
our model will be able
to identify more complex
relationships in our data.
We'll use what's called
a wide and deep model
to predict each wine's price.
For the wide part
of our model, we'll
represent our text
as a bag of words,
which will look like an
array of ones and zeros
indicating the presence or
absence of certain words
from our vocabulary.
In this example, our vocabulary
includes the top 12,000 words
from our entire text corpus
of wine descriptions.
MAX SALTONSTALL: So what
makes this a wide model?
SARA ROBINSON: Good question.
We'll be transforming
each text description
into a single long vector, the
same size as our vocabulary--
in this case, 12,000 elements.
For the deep part
of our model, we'll
create word embeddings, which
is just a fancy mathematical way
of saying that we'll
use vectors to measure
the similarity between words.
Similar words will be closer
together in vector space.
MAX SALTONSTALL: Ah,
so we call this deep
because, instead of using
a single long vector,
we use many shorter
vectors to capture
words that are closely related?
SARA ROBINSON: Exactly.
And the number of vectors
for each description
depends on how big you want
your embedding space to be.
Here, we're using an
eight-dimensional embedding
space.
MAX SALTONSTALL: OK,
I think I get it.
So how do we actually
train this model?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Collab
has everything we need.
It's an interactive and
collaborative Python notebook
that you can access
directly from the browser,
completely free.
To train our model, we'll
use a TPU, which stands
for tensor processing unit--
Google's custom ASIC
designed specifically
for machine learning.
It's just three mouse clicks to
change your runtime in Collab
to use a TPU.
After we select the TPU
runtime, we'll download the data
and convert it to a format
our model will understand.
MAX SALTONSTALL: But what
about all the storage, compute,
and other stuff I need
to do this training?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Good point.
With Collab, we don't have
to worry about managing
any infrastructure.
We just create a notebook and
get straight into building
and training our model.
Let's see what the
model looks like when
we use it to predict how much
a particular bottle of wine
costs.
Pretty good, right?
MAX SALTONSTALL: Yeah.
It looks to be within
about 10% for most of them.
SARA ROBINSON: You can also
run the model yourself,
by clicking the link
in the description.
MAX SALTONSTALL:
And don't forget
to subscribe to the Google
Cloud Platform channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]